I'm very glad that I could conclude
today's Council has some very positive
results particularly narodni given the
fact that we were dealing with some
really difficult issues starting with
the directive on the protection of the
union's financial interests we were also
able to reach our agreement with the
Parliament I'm convinced that this is a
good compromise which will allow ensure
that we can afford I effective attention
to the union's financial interests and
the European Union's budget you know we
also had a very substantive discussions
afternoon on Laurie digital contracts
digital content that's a very important
subject acha Ronnie both trabecular
which has a bearing on consumer
protection in the field of contracts in
respect of the supply of digital content
to customers we've been able to come up
with some good conclusions to serve as a
basis for further work on this issue
lavanya in the course of the working
party meetings but it is a difficult
subject as I said and so it will require
further discussion on the European
public prosecutor's office still some
work remains to be done we would like to
finalize this in spring 2017 we had a
very good discussion over lunch on the
online hate speech we do not want the
companies to remove hundred percent of
those notifications they have to do a
responsible assessment whether it is
hate speech or not according to to the
legal condition